a kodak moment was once synonymous with
photos
the moments of your life are priceless
are you saving them on the right film
kodak gold
at its peak eastman kodak was the early
20th century equivalent of google or
apple
once possessing a near monopoly in the
film business
but the company's days at the top are
now a memory
since the digital revolution unspooled
the company's dominant position
it's released products to try and keep
up some
a far cry from cameras and film and
recently an announcement to produce drug
ingredients
sent its stock price surging and
embroiled the company in a controversy
that is thrusted back in the limelight
which has raised questions amongst
consumers and investors alike
can the company create another kodak
moment
[Music]
george eastman got into the photography
business in 1880
and he pledged to make taking photos as
convenient as the pencil
you can see that notion in an early
slogan you press the button
we do the rest in 1884 he patented a way
of packaging film in roll form
and four years later introduced the
first kodak camera
then in 1889 eastman began selling the
first commercial
transparent roll film which made it
possible for thomas edison to develop
the motion picture camera so it's it's
it's a highly profitable business and
you don't have a whole lot of
competitors
that's basically the business model
right there the company innovated
photographic solutions for
consumers and businesses alike for
example
the record act was a 1920s camera that
allowed banks to photograph
checks to prevent fraud george eastman
died in 1932
but his namesake company stayed focused
on his vision of turning photography
and then film into a pastime for
ordinary people
they had this one product that had a
high level profit margin
that allowed them to do lots of other
things they would get into
lens manufacturing they would get into
the copier business
i mean they had lots of different
businesses but the core of it really was
the profit margin from film
kodak's dominance continued through
world war ii then
competition began to emerge polaroid
released in 1948
a new camera that turned out a finished
picture one minute
after the shutter snapped but kodak
remained in the eyes of some
a monopoly and faced multiple anti-trust
cases from the u.s government
still the company continued introducing
new products
like simpler more affordable movie
cameras let me show you how easy kodak
has made it for you and me with a kodak
instamatic movie camera and with an eye
towards maintaining its position well
into the future
the company in 1978 patented the first
digital camera which saved images onto a
cassette tape
but it was slow on commercializing
digital camera technology
because it feared it would cannibalize
its film business digital photography
was not their prime business
digital photography was largely funded
by the profits made by film
by 1988 kodak had become a mammoth
international company that employed more
than 145
000 people that year it had its highest
earnings ever
the company viewed rival fuji as its
biggest threat
the japanese company was going after
kodak loyalists with promotions and
advertising by 1989 fuji had captured
11 percent of the u.s market for kodak
the days of double-digit growth in its
film business
were over in 1993 the film giant brought
in a ceo from the outside to turn things
around
george fisher was credited with
motorola's resurgence
and when he got to kodak fisher fought
what he viewed as
fuji's unfair advantage in the japanese
market
what we face is in fact a highly
controlled distribution system
that denies kodak full access to japan's
consumer film and paper market the world
trade organization ultimately rejected
u.s claims of japanese protectionism in
photographic
film meanwhile fisher pursued another
priority pushing the company into the
digital era
but it wasn't it wasn't a profitable
business they probably they didn't make
money on any of these products
in 1997 digital imaging could become a
loss leader for the company
that year kodak was on track to lose an
estimated 400 million dollars
and in traditional film products fuji
was continuing to gain market share
that fall kodak slashed 10 000 jobs
at the turn of the millennium a new ceo
entered the scene and introduced a slew
of new products
some of them actually took it entered
the inkjet and digital printer markets
competing head-on with hewlett-packard
canon and epson
so they said all right prints are prints
are the way to go
so we'll sell a home printer for a
reasonable money but unfortunately
the one thing that happened is with this
business is it just never really took
off because people just don't make that
many photographic prints anymore
people stopped printing photos in part
because this happened
every once in a while a revolutionary
product comes along
that changes everything in 2007
apple's always with ucam the iphone
ushered in
a photographic revolution on the back
the biggest thing of note is we got a
two megapixel camera built right in
between 2008 and 2011 kodak's digital
camera sales began to decline year after
year
to survive it sold off some of its
businesses and its patent portfolio
if you look at sales of of of point and
shoot
cameras whether it's film cameras and or
digital cameras
they're basically almost gone in 2012
the company filed for bankruptcy
protection
and got out of the digital camera
business for a new generation
iphone and instagram supplanted kodak as
the brand synonymous with photography
kodak emerged from bankruptcy about a
year later with a new ceo
the kodak brand was is probably one of
the best known brand names in the world
so part of what they
ended up doing was to license that that
word their name
you you name it they put their name on
it the film company pivoted
to commercial printing and put its name
on tablets and smartphones
in 2018 it introduced its own
cryptocurrency
called kodak coin as part of a platform
to help photographers track and license
their work
but over the last decade the company's
stock price has continued to decline
then this happened the coronavirus
crisis the coronavirus death toll rising
and there are new cases of the disease
here in the united states
in july amidst concerns about
availability of american products to
help in the pandemic
president donald trump announced kodak
had won a first of its kind
765 million dollar government loan
under the defense production act my
administration has reached a historic
agreement
with a great american company you
remember this company it's called
from the good old camera age the old
days
to begin producing critical
pharmaceutical ingredients it's called
kodak
was a chemical company they they
produced their own processing
uh chemicals that went with photography
uh
for a while they owned sterling drug
which is a chemical company
uh so so again it it whether people
realize it or not it actually makes
sense for them to do that that's that
was kind of what their core business was
the company's chief executive jim
continenza said he expected the loan to
create 300 jobs in rochester where
kodak's based
and was confident it would go through
well we feel very comfortable that we
can bank on it but it soon became clear
to investors that the deal was far from
done
a misworded alert about the loan that
kodak sent to local media before the
president's announcement
sent the company's stock price on a
roller coaster ride
the deal was put on pause as the sec
looks at how kodak disclosed the loan
and stock option grants to executives
all this happens as the company is
losing money
five million dollars in the second
quarter compared with a profit of 201
million dollars a year ago
kodak a company whose products helped
capture era after era
is still trying to redefine its own
image in the current one